JAKE ARCHIBALD: And we're
seeing a lot of frameworks
now that they are
moving to a model
where they could do
server rendering as well.
Or what's the term for it
that makes data [INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL LEWIS: Oh,
isomorphic JavaScript.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Is-- isomorsic.
Iso--
PAUL LEWIS: Isomorsic?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Is-- is-- is--
PAUL LEWIS: [INAUDIBLE].
JAKE ARCHIBALD: [STUTTERING]
Uh, a few too many of these.
PAUL LEWIS:
[CHUCKLES] Isomorphic.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Isomorsic JavaScript.
PAUL LEWIS: Come on, now.
Come on.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I can do this.
Isomorphic.
Yay.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
isomorsic JavaScript--
I can barely still say it.
So isomorsic--
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, come on now.
Seriously.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK, OK.
PAUL LEWIS: One more.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Here we go.
Isomor--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I bought a PS4 recently.
I've been going on about it.
And I was looking at some of the
literature that comes with it.
One of the big things
that they advertise
is that, hey, did you
know that new in the PS4
is you can, while
you're downloading
level one of the game--
well, as soon as level one is
downloaded, you can
start playing it
even though levels 1 to
99 are still downloading.
PAUL LEWIS: Wow.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And that's
what I was thinking of.
Wow, this is the PS4.
This is the absolute
height of technology.
But the world's been able
to do this for 20 years.
PAUL LEWIS: I think there's
a lot of skill, though,
in dividing up your
web app into things
that need to be there
in the initial burst,
and then things like
the level one stuff,
and level 2 through 99.
I still think that's
much too difficult for us
to get our heads around.
It takes a lot of planning.
And it's OK if it's just sort of
a one-person thing, where they,
like, I do the design,
I do the development,
I do everything myself.
But if you're not
that person and you've
got a big team,
having everybody think
about what is level
one, that's really hard.
Because you've got to understand
exactly how the web gets
built before you can get there.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But
the benefits are huge.
On this blog post I did about
progressive enhancement,
someone, an author of one of
these big web frameworks--
PAUL LEWIS: Who
shall not be named.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We
won't name them.
But they bombed the comments
with like, well, this
is nonsense.
My framework is excellent.
I looked at the documentation
for their framework, which
uses the framework as
an example of the--
PAUL LEWIS: [INAUDIBLE].
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
on 3G, their time
from request to some content
on the screen is seven seconds.
PAUL LEWIS: Ooh.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But even with
a full cache on a fast as you
like connection, it's
still three seconds,
because they're CPU-bound.
I know, right?
It's just like--
and as soon as I
saw that, I was just like,
win this argument, then.
I can do this with data.
And it was just normal content.
I mean, there was a
few JavaScript things,
like open this, collapse that.
You could do that
all after the fact.
PAUL LEWIS: So I
guess this comes back
to the whole-- like, Twitter
did this years ago, didn't they,
where they went, hey, we've
shifted to client side
and everything is awesome.
And then they went,
actually, doing
what the web was doing, which is
serving some HTML over the wire
in the initial request, that's
where the cool stuffs are.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes, this is
my progressive enhancement
rant, clearly, right?
But what was it?
It was like a six times
speedup they saw so that--
PAUL LEWIS: I don't know.
I don't actually remember.
I know they did say,
we've gone and done it
because performance, yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But then,
to be fair to frameworks,
like, I do like
how they're stating
to go with this
server-rendering approach,
what they call isomorphic.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
You got it right.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I got
it right this time.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, every time you
say it, it's like [MUMBLING].
JAKE ARCHIBALD: [MUMBLING]
But that's-- this feels like
the right approach.
I feel like it's--
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's a
Band-Aid over the solution,
over the problem of
slowing everything down.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
They made this problem, right?
This whole thing was
avoidable if you just
did what we did, right?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's it.
By leveraging good caching,
first render stuff, and service
worker, your performance
problems are solved.
[MUSIC PLAYING]